and speak up
we're definitely today to take take on
the work runs unknown we're getting 10
days proximity to definitive anniversary
of as fast as from 12
if stating what is commemorative I
should like to think that rather than
remembering in any you're not
remembering in the inning and that which
we know onst and historicist sense that
would say elaborated for us including
six years ago keep in mind that since
ancient times
every member Asian is a performative
generation that we would revise and sets
out new minds the possibility
accordingly
I should like to take a few moments and
think about it anyways panel under the
rubric of three terms didn't seem real
humanism
and dignity the Sharia and 10-years Nina
that's thing I'll start out by
describing hi and oriental here in
relation to these terms I think the
bearings of my attitude camera mark
recently made by a well-regarded
historian of the contemporary art world
I mean today was equally well regarded
as an activist palatable for the
movement central plateau the revolution
epicenter one of those humanistically
referred to as the youth of the
revolution on a hot sunny Sunday
afternoon this past June as he and I
walk the length of Avenue happy with you
buff which has become near border of the
revolution and participating one of its
main spot
yeah today remark to that looking at
what is happening to meet you now
when can I hope it ask how evolutions or
evokes uprisings and instructions are
being formed not only in the
contemporary era but in some world but
also anywhere else in the world today
there is clearly an indestructible dream
of a better world to which historians
should apply themselves in English
opinion then he stopped and he looked at
me and said almost as an afterthought in
no yakety the analysis spent spent on
made a revolution in Africa wanting to
provide in Tunisia still serves as a
template for understanding what is
happening here now and that whatever the
outcome of the upcoming election for the
Constituent Assembly will preserve the
revolution will be whether the disparate
institutions that emerged in the
interest he sees of the state of the
market which generated the subjects of
the revolution will preserve ear in
their anarchic dynamics his phrase was
that a mere investment the wheel well
this is a question of poetry it is also
a question of the types of socialities
articulation
these remarks prompted me to recall
Finland's prominent role in the Algerian
revolution as what I call the craftsman
of intelligence it also reminded me of
the Carey's miss of the struggle to
deserve the indestructible dream about a
world against comfortable ban on an
event or Madonna mustered into ground
the Revolution and the spontaneous
intelligence of the people which i think
is currently a state in Tunisia right
now expressed the elephant local
metaphor Cheviot the bubbler the
legitimacy of the live illusion and most
definitely is what I have in mind by the
gym you see this has to do with
something Fenelon wrote from the view
looking kept buddies during soccer money
in 1959 which was published in the seats
before by must there always whatever mr.
month began and then of course in
English in 69 is forward together to
revolution he wrote that the greatest
danger for Africa was the absence of the
geology having in mind the way in which
the processes historically entail and
perhaps constitutive of the long
we was information beginning at the end
of the 17th century and commonly
revolutions of 1848 in generally
secularization in the colonial context
that rather than precipitating the
decline of pragmatism unity reinforces
and extends their application this is to
recognize religion tribalism as
conceptually categories of secular
modernity as if we are all well
acquainted with its Adventist functions
of anthropology and that were to be
articulate ways of living and thinking
falling outside of the parameters of
liberalism Zooniverse history into
formation is well situated within that
mystery and more dramatic way of putting
it is that the historical effective
revolutions application under the theory
Elizabeth has been to replace all
population formations with new ones in
accordance with the logic of which was
implemented this transformation in their
the ball months of life into manageable
forces has long been construed to be
functional politics that same is for the
tendency for type of management however
also prompt specters of performance of
human thinking in action that I'm
fighting so readily
subjugated
along these line think we're going
Claude McKay's back a work that reports
a sequence of pointedly non who was he
performances and acted over a lifetime
that were able to incite precisely by
embodying all most emblematic what he
called vagabondage a well-known
expression which is his poem outcast for
the dim regions whence my father's came
my spirit finally arrived on longs where
it's felt but never heard my lips would
frame my soul would seem forgotten
gemstones I wouldn't go back to dark
ease into peace but the Great Western
world holds me if he and I may never
hope for all these lovely was alien God
I bend my knee
leave me is lost forever lost so my key
thing is when I was my heart and I must
walk away there like a ghost among the
sons of the earth a thing apart where I
was born
barber money decline under the white
men's men's by the time Simon does not
exhibit a second based or assumed by a
sense of loss you know and references
loss rather one that is articulated in
the
whether to express what is imagining and
it can only be imagined to me the primal
inexpressible the subject of this
articulation is not in mourning but
rather is compelled by the discrepancy
between what can and cannot be expressed
with can and cannot be comprehensively
represented so continuum creation
in this sense yes the Vagabond aesthetic
but not as many mean understands the
better to them to be something that is
to say the dissolution of the static
distinction is not indicative of a
desire for return improper or pouring
and integrity in relation to things it
indicates the desire to be free among
things we can barely designate the
spider decided the blues noting thereby
that the oxymoronic finger is not
melancholia or as Curtis Mayfield States
and we the people who are darker than
room the poem that is one plaintiff in
the case sign but so to more explicitly
concerned with the non reactionary force
according expression we the people who
are darker than blue don't let us hang
around this town and those others say
whatever they say come true there's only
three mark about ideology
nonetheless and he construed this room
call for criticism
indeed it is appalled to reimagine the
possibilities of secularization through
recognizing the tremendous reach of its
machines of desire and imagination the
success of which has ended on the
Cartesian distinction between me
and ways of thinking selenium balance
factor graphic terms this distinction is
a principal factor in the theology of
modernity seemingly pathological
inability to fulfill its promise the
universal legs it is informed by the
internal dynamics of a Christian though
in the solution
none of which concerns family directly
at all and only conceptually as a
particular historical instance of the
political employment of ritualized
superstition
it must be underscored however that his
criticism is not the performance of that
receipts nearly to become something else
in terms of the current conceptual as
well as a political order or Western
modernity rather it seems to compel that
order to recognize the full range of
forces in as engaged not as products
that engagement but as sets of facts and
the powers and practices the material
existence
historical implementation and
manipulation of which warrant
tracing such a performance calls for
something else other than theology a
viable candidate misconduct may very
well simply be poetry but poetry
relation to consciousness that is on
paper
as soon as fan inflated which brings two
for the question about how desired
functions or is articulated as an
element of what might call techniques of
thinking alternatively might qualify
only refer to this as attitude of it
meet in the sense of timely or eventful
inning and as he says the adjective
should be given its full weight for its
expression as well as its source is at
what they practice that is a living
style of spontaneous creation what can
be meant by spontaneous creation except
that the poetic image is a material form
of an imagination as the technique of
living essential to thinking in the
world as humans
to ask this is to ask what defines the
human for whom and that situation says
well within the ambit of the tradition
of radical black thinking imagination
that we find found on on this question
of human you know stall point of
distinction between panels concept and
the Enlightenment humanist concept of
man as an abstraction the lineage that
so captured adornments meditations of
the European crisis causing him to
conclude that the human necessarily
requires the nonhuman as its principal
the lineage that Sylvia winters boldly
and haffley demonstrates we have no part
of it and need not do stuff in order to
create an epic award asked in this
manner the question is concerned between
beans as articulations of determinable
sets of life practices and grammars by
grammars I mean whatever the new bio
says that which enables the members of
the community to judged correctly that
is to say to correctly link the
discontinuities appearing in the world
violence objects material gestures
discourses to descriptions and to relate
experience in certain of those
descriptions as a feeling of fact even
more precisely I mean something along
the lines proposed by the ancient
sumerians Aurelia with father Brahma has
a technology of imagined
a set of relief from some things in
reality and each other our articulation
as constant in the world this is a
question of discovering rehab with
expression whereas balloon says in the
voice of Algeria the voice the speech
acronym the spoken word orders the world
power and music which is to say that
with transformations of grammar and
grammars are always open always though
we cannot or we always must remember a
transformative dissonance in basic
perception in the very world of
perception the moment of FSOC only
limited in other words the revolutionary
struggle is that an emergent collective
imagination striving to institute an
important worldly intelligence turning
to this question of the relationship
between language perception imagined
a technology with money which is where
legitimacy and here humanism meet I
invited by Albert barese recently
professed realization that all the
wedding expressions represent or express
human feels how humans are constantly
and effectively and so what they are
aware of this means that local
circumstances and predicaments and the
pneumatic procedures evolved to cope
with them may have worldwide
implications and applications
indeed marine plants such as the
function efficient which is also to say
poetry which is to say metaphor so that
whereas social science surveys are
really about one place at a time the
local metaphor is about all and I'm in
this relationship between fiction
metaphor and thinking the world is
humans I recall another moment Marie
when he told that noble fictions
ultimate fiction is an attempt to order
chaos you see Marie said I now think in
terms of particle several waves that's
the way we conceive of entropy which is
chaos and the one thing we have or the
only
in knew about it is to use that
endowment that we have that Joyce was
talking about Louie Furman to be in a
lockable modality of the visible of the
audible of the conceptual the concept is
an attempt to bring some form without
that you just have chaos
so you've got to have some sense of form
whether it's up down outside inside
ramens player or whatever he needs here
style
so everything's peachy it's a matter of
finding an adequate metaphor that would
be fermented with the complexities and
possibilities of our surroundings that's
something we simply have seen and so the
old English fiction when a person talks
about documentation it means documenting
concepts what serious fiction such as
poetry tries to do is to bring the
deepest the most comprehensive insights
to bear of money speaking of
documentation what we recall fiction
even nourished and before in the
consignor and for the authority and the
jacket and that can be called this and
more happy that is my nieces and what he
calls documentation they called the
emissary
by which they indicated the living
community of humans articulated and
sustained with poetic expression of
profoundly serious imagination I could
go on and I will as we are talking about
documentation and these residences
matter as fiction inform the preeminent
Arabic by McHale carry a novelist follow
the thought was the young men setting as
a phenomenal value in Tunisia and at
least must have known
we just lost like here the cancer and
the occasion of the seminar on the novel
can mean that at the young students out
beginning with and litigate stated it's
personal fundamental commitment to the
principle that I like to perform and
content in the sense of expanding the
possibility of giving out of the corner
pocket and that owns being transformed
by that content while at the same time
in the grave from scratch formations
that principle was behind his unwavering
father did a feather why experiment is
revolution against establishments of the
nominee which was the struggle to
disengage the mouth is a viable and any
motive representing how many of us live
our lives in this world now from the
necessities of historical who's wasn't
formations of life this remote is not
only against the general form of the
novel but also against the consecration
of form it is the constant attempt at
innovation of form that embodies was
purported embodies the content like the
language that is in harmony with the
atmosphere and during the process of
innovative creativity and I'm a native
died here for Thought functions as what
he calls an emetic phrase the draft
worth melodies and not the conveyor
means this is a rather complex planet
and at the same time clearly resonant
with angry Libertines remark in mines
novel dr. Faustus that the development
section of Sonata form was the revenues
were subjected elimination as I said a
moment ago
there are many residences in harmonic
dissonance and to note another Gramsci
remarks in his notebooks the beginning
of critical elaboration is consciousness
of what one really is mainly to know
yourself as a product of the historical
process that has taken place so far and
left in you an infinity of traces
without the benefit of an Indian ploy
what is needed is to initiate such an
inventory a different Court is struck if
we follow Edward Sayid and quietly
change inventory to itinerary so now we
are going to somewhere have been mean
somewheres else
and the tasks to come up with a plan of
travel on the spot there's no bearing
other than where we are now and means of
itinerary kind of new players to the
movies here I'm not only here in cement
them off they may know mr. Tate
i allude apportion is you mark and
deliberately sells for Bernie me because
we are precisely not innocent of
anything other than life that no one
really does provide us including sites
without this pathology on precedent in
front of we have to skip over the long
passage about gamma 30 10
of course we all know the call it's a
shock routine as about what we
don't tell me what I wanted to walk
through the genealogy comes out of I see
their life by hidden meant even free in
that shop yeoman are either path which
becomes key phrase it moccasins routine
as a definition of perpetual road back
here on ahead and there's a key concept
here with the call and confidence and
which is what the comedians play name
for evolutionarily follow the Kurama
people's question about by Eric's plays
an answer and inside I wasn't I'd listen
to what families very specific this
notion we belong to a very particular
genealogy that has worked and indeed
Shady's will to live as a definitive
element of perpetual revolution is the
dignity of humanity and the point of all
this is not moving to market there is an
Arab or Islamic element
the factories sites I'm useless sources
huge the most convenience of these
values of the elevator still elude our
comprehension and the supplied
Keynesians today refer to what they call
a top left to receive cochlea in here in
Keynesian ethics when they talk about
the spontaneity that which the people
that fascinate established structures of
order and all the bloody chaos through
this dark days for the gentleman
they gave gas form a very sense in these
epochs in innocence arrogance asian
union underscores for one for the
historical account of the formation of
this emergent revolutionary intelligence
that exposes a radical humans and this I
think live in the gist about in today's
remarks about an indestructible do for a
better world to which is going to apply
themselves in the city and I encourage
them that their own sense of rhythmic
attitude is crucial to such a little
sedation furthermore our inability to
comprehend the ways in which the Asian
revolution is the survival and date
pronounced patterns is our ignorance
when those legacy this
you know he's a little more I am the
poet and though that I must be one more
time a little bit because I want to
attend to a specific era living from
other document who is widely recognized
as the president national poet Athenian
and whose expression trajectory is not
representative Keynesian human but
humanity and his work as to display the
role Toa treatment process
wonderful movie reminds by the finest of
them the avaya Alvarado that operated by
hankies - nice jacket that shiny diamond
there were many that back many work a
methodical but they are all that I have
but I would suggest that party : India
you know Sabha in father Donahue insulin
but the ship right the shewag method
would be significant when anyone than
the amendment and a very very positive
step and soon as the water - and to
disempower Bob and the food is the Baba
Rama do you look into the ashes and so
mean flat like your shining shoes I
cannot bear your stare my Tunis my
brother burnt I have here I have no one
I have no ears
I have no mouth as you can see I mean I
come back to life
and I may return clear and sharp as a
Cossack row don't give me a pen to write
with because my fingers through with the
terrible fire across the sky you smell
the fragrance of barbecue what you tell
your friends to artists and they
understand that winter does it autumns
door I am seventeen soon as a loss but I
subsist on conviction and rain ice
phenomena I am greater who's who as a
quota
destiny God I am the other news soon as
the war created ashes